So I have a few different, absolutely crazy
things to catch you up on relating to one
of Donald Trump's closest advisers, Kellyanne
Conway.
Kellyanne has announced that she's going to
be leaving the White House at the end of the
month, meaning in just a few days because
of a need to, quote, focus on the family now.
If you're not aware, Kellyanne Conway has
been just a disgusting Trump sycophant for
years, but she happens to be married to George
Conway, who is an anti Trump Republican and
who, in fact, has become one of the loudest
anti Trump Republican voices on the Internet
and part of this anti Trump Republican coalition
called the Lincoln Project.
Well, in the middle of all this.
Their daughter, Claudia Conway, became an
outspoken anti Trump personality online.
Clearly, things are really bad for the family.
And so Kellyanne Conway has now announced
that she's leaving the White House.
George Conway is leaving the Lincoln Project
and leaving Twitter.
And it seems that this clearly is the right
move for them as a family.
And part of the constant dysfunction of the
Trump White House has just bled over and is
ruining so many people's lives.
And clearly, the decision made by the Conway
parents must in part be because of the insanity
that their children have been pulled into.
Kellyanne Conway putting out a statement saying
about her and her husband that, quote, We
disagree about plenty, but we are united on
what matters most.
The kids are four.
Children are teens and tweens, starting a
new academic year in the middle school and
high school that will be conducted remotely
from home for at least a few months.
As millions of parents nationwide know, kids
doing school from home requires a level of
attention and vigilance that is as unusual
as these times.
This is completely my choice and my voice.
In time, I will announce future plans for
now and for my beloved children.
It will be less drama and more mama.
Their daughter Claudia also tweeted over the
weekend that she was going to be taking a
break from Twitter.
And listen, this all is a horrible situation.
But in the middle of this, their daughter
in a now deleted video also accused Kellyanne
Conway of physical abuse.
And again, that video has since been deleted.
There have been notable Twitter exchanges
between mom and daughter.
For example, when Kellyanne tweeted about
Herman Cain, quote, Herman Cain led a remarkable
life and will be missed.
He loved his family, the country and the Lord.
He triumphed in business, beat cancer and
was a voice for freedom.
God bless you and yours, Herman.
Her daughter, Claudia Conaway responded, Yes,
it is sad, but wasn't your administration
complicit in his death?
Yikes.
So here's the bottom line.
I don't I don't know if Kellyanne Conway abused
her daughter.
I don't know anything about that.
This is clearly a family in struggle.
It should be up to them to figure out what's
best for the family.
I'm less interested in the gossip element
and more interested in the theme, which is
that everything Trump touches turns to manure.
How many lives and I'm not talking about you
know, you can talk about millions of lives
have been ruined by Donald Trump's presidency
in terms of financial repercussions or the
friends and relatives of the people who died
of Corona virus who didn't have to.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm just saying people who work for Trump,
the people Trump brings around him the number
of ruined lives, people arrested, people fired,
people becoming global laughing stocks.
Kellyanne Conway is the 550 seventh person
to leave the Trump administration since the
beginning.
Trump sister recorded has been recorded recently
saying horrible things about Trump.
Trump's niece wrote a devastating book about
him.
Melania is now reportedly recorded saying
horrible things about Trump and his own children,
which I'll talk about next.
We just need a normal presidency and a normal
president.
And as I tweeted a couple of days ago, and
it seemed to resonate with a lot of people,
Joe Biden's presidency, if we get one, would
probably be one of the most boring in a very
long time.
And that's perfectly fine with me now.
As parents, it does seem the Conways realize
that this public battle where they've been
on opposite sides of this presidency has been
terrible for their family and their kids.
That's good.
I guess it's better that they recognize that
now instead of in another six months, we could
say.
But it would have been far better for them
to recognize that three and a half years ago.
Let's now talk about the Melania revelations.